donc si j'ai bien compris le mec si on
ne fait pas rire il meurt tous à lahti
relou d'accord mais on a un truc que je
comprends pas pourquoi ils font appel à
nous alors ils ont des infiltrés à marge
plus déchirant été question les mecs ils
sont bloqués dans les embouteillages
donc on est juste là pour préparer un
terrain d'accord donc on soit peu
exploité quoi parce que genre il n'aime
pas prendre le métro du coup nous on
leur fait gagner du temps fallait pas se
présenter à ce blues tu voulais pas le
faire non mais oh tu sais combien ça
paye le stand-up
c'est pas tout ça mais on va faire
simple
jules toi tu passes devant lui et tu te
votre nagl bien dégueulasse ça marche
ensuite il nous faut un truc chelou
inattendu quoi après non en fait moi
j'ai passé avec morpheus et je veux
faire style je ne contrôle plus le chien
m'échappe n'importe quoi sam seddas au
côté de lui et tu lâches une grosse
caisse en mode j'ai pas fait exprès
d'accord c'est après tout ça le nicolas
il rigole pas c'est qu'il va sombrer
donc on sort le san giorgio a on le tue
non on tue pas au fait des trucs
montayral improvise on fait des trucs
drôles via de l'hélium c'est bien ça
l'histoire des trucs on fait pour aller
brouter poil et du coup comment c'est
qu'il va sombrer le nicolas
ces jeunes viennent chez nous et il
commence à trembler d'accord ok te dit
pas du tout enchaîner sur le boulou
qu'en fait non non je fais du stand-up
je suis pas habitué à péter sur des
mutants dépressifs chez nous
c'est marche vers la cime je vais
bientôt me casser la gueule la prochaine
fois c'est par monsieur ouais ça va
taper pas nico nico nique nique ta mère
reculé à remonter trop quand on est
surpris j'ai détruit oui je suis là je
suis prêt voilà il est ingérable et
coûteux c'est un truc débile dire qu'il
rigole pas du tout la dégager un groupe
se met à trembler la scène où qu'ils
aillent vite
oui oui je suis prête une vraie
et ça me laisse une caisse
il trempe de plus en plus
c'est pas le consomme la champions
ok j'ai remis de cette danse non non
c'est bon c'est bon je peux le faire
plus tard tiré sur mon dos tiré ce monde
est marrant
[Musique]
on
on a besoin d'une équipe de nettoyage
ici on a merdé
[Musique]
on écoute tout armé de chez toi tu
proposes tu prends une douche on parle
de sa demande
[Musique]
défoncée et comment on sait qu'il est
pas un
non c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
devient c'est quelque chose qu'on y est
moi je pense qu'on peut l'attraper m
ta mère
[Musique]
sur la bien fait de laisser poussins non
il est pas dépressif fichten 9 forcément
n'est possible
ça va quoi j'me m'arrive quelque chose
je sais pas d'où on sait rien 28 mar en
titane boîte vous le faire maria fait
qu'un point et nous lancer reviendra
plus tard je cherchais une salle
d'urgence
c'est moussa fall et maintenant j'en
sais rien mon deuxième prénom c'est
valérie c'est moi c'est marrant ça c'est
pas quand je touche de rythme parce qu
apparemment comme ça c'est bien
c'est bizarre de faire ça quand même
c'est bizarre je vais faire
à
ça va les donner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]